Come on! You're a hawkeye. And who the hell
are you. Welcome back everyone this is going to
be my full marvel hawkeye episode 1 video they're
finally dropping episodes so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes just like all the marvel disney plus
series there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
obviously most of them for the avengers movies
that hawkeye was in but also the matt fraction
hawkeye comic book run also probably a lot of
daredevil easter eggs that you may have seen in
the background too i'm doing a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave your favorite easter
egg or moment from the episode on the video
but careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet we'll be talking about everything
since they dropped the first two episodes together
i'll be doing a separate video for episode two
that we'll post later tonight but we'll just
start at the beginning and go through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs moments and all
this foreshadowing they're setting up for later
episodes starting with the title of the episode
so episode one was titled never meet your heroes
which is a reference to kate bishop actually
meeting her hero hawkeye at the end of the episode
just to clarify when this is taking place
the present day of the series is actually set
two years after avengers end game so we're around
christmas 2025 and that means that it is the
latest we've ever been in marvel phase four in a
new project not counting loki and sylvie going to
the end of the timeline if you really want to get
technical that's the furthest forward we've been
originally i actually thought that this was going
to be christmas 2024 because i thought it was
going to overlap with spider-man no way home but
it sounds like this is taking place even after
spider-man no way home so after doctor strange
fixes whatever spider-man does to break reality
but as i said the story of the hawkeye series
is loosely based on the matt fraction hawkeye
comic book run where he trains kate bishop to
become his successor but they both continue to
exist in marvel comics going forward and both use
the hawkeye name the thing about hawkeye is that
he's not precious about his name like he doesn't
care that she uses it he's happy to let her use
the name obviously for the mcu they're playing a
little bit differently he treats her more like a
burden when he first runs into her like okay i
got a problem to clean up need to make it home
for christmas with my family so let's just wrap
this up as quickly as possible the whole idea
is that she just slowly grows on him through the
rest of the series until eventually they become
friends most of you are probably loosely familiar
with kate bishop's origin story in the comics they
made a couple minor changes to it just to fit it
within what's happened in the mcu so far though
but the marvel intro logo that they're using is
just the same updated marvel phase 4 intro that
they started using during shangxi so it's just the
most recent one they've been using they do have
custom hawkeye intros and custom credits which
are all designed to look like the matt fraction
hawkeye comic book run art by david aha so it's
actually probably one of the coolest looking
marvel intros so far they try to do custom ones
for each of the different series you also might
have noticed too that during the outro credit
sequence they show you things that are happening
in the future of the series so it's almost like a
teaser for the next episode over the credits but
the actual episode starts in a flashback to 2012
in kate bishop's family's home in new york city
it's the day of the avengers battle of new york
it picks up right before the start of the battle
the camera does a quick scan of her childhood
room just to show you all of her trophies and
pictures just to give you a little idea of her
background how she's really good at sports she's
really good at archery all these different skills
that she's going to eventually develop even more
to become the next hawkeye she's athletic she's
super resourceful like she's able to eavesdrop
on her parents while they're having their
conversation in another room which they also pay
off later in the episode and present day too with
her eavesdropping just listening to conversations
the pet vet toy here is also foreshadowing for
her taking in lucky the pizza dog during the
matt fraction run hawkeye was the person to rescue
lucky the pizza dog in some of the dynamics were
a little bit different i'll explain some of the
differences as we go along through those moments
in the episode all this plot that they're setting
up with her parents arguing about how they're
running out of money they're gonna go bankrupt
they might have to sell their penthouse apartment
is all meant to be foreshadowing for what happens
with her mother eventually developing ties to the
mob in new york city this is where they start
to change some things about kate bishop's origin
story so in the comics the reason why she's such
a hawkeye fan girl is because when she was young
she eventually tails her father trying to find
out what he's doing and learns that he's having
this meeting with a mob she gets captured by the
mob hawkeye and the other avengers just happened
to get involved and wind up saving her life
so when hawkeye saves her life from the mob
she winds up idealizing him and grows up wanting
to be a vigilante during the episode they just
tie that to the avengers battle of new york
and she sees this scene of hawkeye taking out
all the shitauri on the rooftop and then swinging
down it's the same shot that they put in all the
avengers trailers and all the big highlight reels
that they played the last several years her mother
referencing solutions falling out of the sky was
meant to be a reference to the chitauri invasion
the avengers coming to save them iron man fell
out of the sky saving them from that giant bomb
you could also call it a reference to thor and
his hammer both falling out of the sky literally
reigning superheroes in new york city they also
kind of set up the dynamic that she has with her
mother so even as a child it sounds like she had a
strained relationship with her that kind of plays
into what's happening during present day it sounds
like her father had some kind of plan to get them
out of debt and whatever that plan was it sounds
like her mother just kind of picked it up and
ran with it after he died and that's what became
bishop's security in present day the business that
she runs which they kind of imply is a little bit
shady and i think that's all meant to be about her
ties to the mafia the pep talk she gets from her
father about being able to control choices that
you make despite bad weather you might encounter
it's just meant to foreshadow a lot of her actions
she takes later when she's being a vigilante with
hawkeye in the whole thing with the trick that her
mother pulls with the food is also meant to
foreshadow that she has some skills herself
like showing you that she's not just some simple
rich housewife after we find out that her father's
dead we go to the funeral kate bishop vows to
protect them in case the aliens ever come back
turns out they did wind up coming back twice
thanos came back twice with two different armies
and she asked her mother for a bow so that she can
train to be just like hawkeye become a superhero
someday one of the other things they do with
these custom opening hawkeye title sequences
is show you the rest of her story as she grows up
to present day like basically give you a montage
of her training herself until we get to present
day and then when we do pick up in present day
after avengers end game like it says present day
this is meant to be like i said two years after
avengers end game so it's christmas in 2025. we're
at the school that she's attending right now and
they focus on the sign that says stain tower which
is a reference to obadiah stain from the first
iron man movie i'm not sure which school this is
but it's in the new york city area he was crazy
rich just like tony stark's family so i think one
of the reasons why they use his name in particular
isn't just to make a cool iron man reference
it's meant to be a reference to a really evil
rich person and there's a lot of those in the
hawkeye series because it's all about these
really wealthy people in new york city with ties
to the mob like the really shady black market
auction that we see later in the episode but they
use this clock tower sequence to show you some of
the skills that she's picked up over the years
like she scales the outside of the building then
lands the trick shot eventually but the big twist
is she winds up destroying the entire clock tower
it's sort of meant to give you a vibe for the
tone of the series like there's a lot of crazy
action but it's kind of meant to be like die hard
in the mcu they use comedy and action together in
the same breath the same way that the die hard
movies did also during the die hard series a lot
of times during the christmas holiday he's trying
to make it home to his family but can't because
of a bunch of villains that he's trying to stop
then they cut to broadway in new york city where
hawkeye has brought his family or his kids at
least to see the captain america rogers musical
and they no joke actually did it like a straight
up musical they wrote a whole bunch of lyrics a
whole bunch of song and dance numbers obviously
it's mostly focusing on captain america like he's
the main protagonist so it covers everything
from his origin story during world war ii
up through the avengers movies most of the musical
that we see though takes place during the events
of the battle of new york and if you're a big
avatar the last airbender fan it's a lot like
the ember island players episode of avatar the
last airbender at least the way they played in
the episode where team avatar has to watch
a recap of their adventures in the form of
a silly play but it's really bad so it makes
them super embarrassed it's kind of cringy so
hawkeye has that same cringy reaction to all this
and even turns his hearing aids off i love that
they even worked in captain america's trademark
catchphrase to the lyrics i can do this all day
he does start to have a mini panic attack when he
starts thinking about black widow they said that
this is going to be a recurring thing throughout
the series like his mind will continue to go back
to natasha so she's a big part of the series
even though she's dead in present day also we
have all the elena bulova stuff with her trying
to kill hawkeye that'll probably pay out later
in the series he jokes about the play not being
totally accurate pointing at ant-man that guy
wasn't there like they have a version of ant-man
who's part of the avengers battle of new york
they have a thanos was right joke scribbled and
graffiti in the bathroom post all the memes he
didn't seem particularly bothered by it but
then a random dude bugs him for an autograph
while he's mid piss with his out the funny thing
about this is this actually happens to a lot of
celebrities in real life so if you've ever seen
a celebrity in the bathroom do not be this guy
do not be the dude who asks someone for an
autograph while they're taking a piss they
wind up bailing on the play about halfway through
his family comes out to meet him you'll remember
his daughter lila from avengers end game she's
played by joe russo's daughter in real life and
he also calls her hawkeye so technically there's
like three versions of hawkeye in the mcu now
she literally references black widow as his other
kids come out his youngest son you'll remember is
named nathaniel pietro barton after quicksilver
and then not too far away at grand central station
kate bishop arrives back in the city walking
past an ad for the rogers musical that we saw
there are a couple different times during the
episodes where the rogers musical ads show up
they kind of foreshadow that her mother's getting
remarried to swordmaster i'll explain him from the
comics because he's a big hawkeye character from
the classic comics but they kind of changed him a
little bit for the tv show but they do this big
fly over new york city in the landscape and all
these different landmarks they're showing you all
these different places are places where they'll
have big fight scenes and big action scenes later
in the series so most of the series takes place
in and around midtown new york city between hell's
kitchen on the west side and then on the east side
is also around the same area where the avengers
tower used to be like broadway for instance where
they just were watching this musical is right
next to hell's kitchen so i know a lot of you
are wondering about daredevil easter eggs and
references there are daredevil things going on
in the episodes and vincent d'onofrio's kingpin is
rumored to have a cameo in later episodes so i'll
talk about that when we get to those parts of the
episodes the whole thing with her mother asking
her to put on a red dress and come to this auction
with her is just kind of give you an idea for her
personality like she shows up wearing a tuxedo
instead just to show you that she's more of a
tomboy like she's not someone who walks around in
a lot of dresses you also notice that even before
she runs into hawkeye she's wearing purple like
purple is her color because purple is hawkeye's
color in the comics they reveal the reason why
there are so many swords all over her childhood
home is because swordmaster is now dating her
mother and they're engaged to be married in the
comics swordmaster's real name is Jack Duquesne he
was hawkeye's mentor but during the series they're
playing him more like a villain they have the
big scene with hawkeye taking his kids to dinner
they talked to his wife laura i know everybody was
wondering what happened to her in the trailer is
she dead what's going on they just didn't show her
because there wasn't a lot of footage with her in
the episodes the whole reason why he's here alone
with his kids and she's not there is because he's
trying to make up for lost time that he missed
when they were growing up while he was busy
working for nick fury shield and then the avengers
the waiter brings him complimentary food thanking
him for saving the city during the battle of new
york and avengers end game this kind of makes him
uncomfortable several times in the episodes just
people saying oh thank you so much oh i'm such a
big fan of yours his whole thing is that he really
does not like this kind of attention he actually
actively tries to avoid it like later when he's
talking to kate bishop in future episodes he talks
about how he's not trying to sell any kind of
merch like some of the other avengers characters
they said at the whole running plot with jack
duquesne's uncle armond who winds up getting
murdered later you find out a little bit about
him he seems kind of shady too but he doesn't seem
quite as evil as swordmaster or quite as shady
as what's going on with kate bishop's mother
like she overhears the argument with armond and
her mother where it seems like he's found out some
secret about her business and it's super sus but
her mother tries to blow it off like it's nothing
in the comics it was her father that had the ties
to the mop i think just for the series they just
switched that and made it her mother instead her
eavesdropping on the really shady black market
auction is just a callback to the beginning of
the episode with her eavesdropping on her parents
when the auctioneer says they're traveling back
in time for the first item that's a reference to
avengers endgame and the time heist mission but
they start by auctioning off a dinosaur skull
then they auction off hawkeye's ronin sword
and hawkeye's roman costume you notice that
swordmaster is obsessed with getting hawkeye's
ronin sword and i think that's because of a
connection that he probably has to hawkeye ronin
during the five-year time jump like it seems
like there are a number of different characters
associated with the mob that have ties to him that
go back to that five year time jump the auctioneer
makes several references to many very powerful mob
members being killed by the sword itself when his
uncle holds up number 124 that's a reference to
avengers 124 an issue where they faced off against
swordmaster the number 102 that swordmaster holds
up is also a reference to avengers number
102 which is a grim reaper storyline in the
big hawkeye storyline most of these numbers are
all just sword master specific avengers comics
and i think they're trying to use them just to
tell you this swordmaster has deep ties to the mob
he's doing something shady also i think the reason
why he's so obsessed with ronan's sword hawkeye
ronan probably killed someone or almost killed
him during the five-year time jump they set up
this whole running plot with his inheritance and
his uncle like oh i might not have money now but
i will inherit a bunch eventually foreshadowing
him killing his uncle with the ronin sword at the
end of the episode if it wasn't clear from all the
clues in the first couple of episodes i am pretty
certain that it was him who killed his uncle with
the ronin sword then they revealed the tracksuit
mafia is about to hit the auction trying to steal
a watch that was from the avengers compound they
don't really explain who the watch belonged to
because none of the avengers really wore watches
except for tony stark who wore a wristband which
was part of his iron man gear with part of his
suit tapped into it but the watch itself does not
look like iron man's dark tech the number 268 is a
reference to avengers 268 which is a big kang the
conqueror storyline who is a time travel villain
controlling the timeline in the mcu as we know so
far so the watch a time piece king the conqueror
time travel you get the connection just reminding
you about king the conqueror during the future of
marvel phase four thank you very much loki and
sylvie kind of weird to see a king the conqueror
easter egg in a ground level action story like
hawkeye but the whole vibe that they want to get
across here with kate bishop is that she feels
in this scene here during the attack like she
did during the battle of new york only this time
she's trying to go full hawkeye being a superhero
and use all these skills that she's learned
over the years so she puts on the ronin costume
and starts going after all the tracksuit bros
the funny way they have of talking saying bro
in every single sentence even on their van it
says trust a bro that's right out of the matt
fraction hawkeye run like every other word out
of their mouth is bro they're kind of like this
bumbling group of idiots during the series and
during the hawkeye comic book run it didn't seem
like swordmaster recognized kate bishop inside
the mask but he does get surprised at the sight
of the hawkeye rodent costume like ronin what
that's why i said i think that he had a run-in
with hawkeye ronin during that five year time jump
and is why he's so obsessed with hawkeye's sword
but if it wasn't clear nobody knows at
this point at least nobody in new york city
knows that hawkeye was ronin they think that
ronan was a completely separate ninja vigilante
then even though you don't actually see his face
till later in the episode this character that she
fights here who gets kind of surprised by her and
is not in a tracksuit is kazi he's also called the
clown in the comics he's sort of like a marvel
parody of the joker character like he actually
wears clown makeup later in the series he's one
of the big antagonists during the matt fraction
hawkeye comic book run and within the mcu series
he's just a bigger part of the tracksuit mafia but
he is also somebody who has ties to kingpin in the
comics there are several characters in the hawkeye
series that have ties to kingpin which is why i
start talking about a lot of daredevil easter eggs
kate bishop then winds up saving lucky the
pizza dog and taking him back to her apartment
they never really explained what was going on with
the watch or why someone wanted it stolen or who
it belonged to but they do kind of imply that a
lot of people had stolen things from the rubble
of that final battle with thanos in the avengers
compound it's sort of like what they were doing
with the vulture in spider-man homecoming
with him trading in a lot of black market
tech stolen from the rubble of the chatauri
invasion kate winds up giving lucky a slice
of pizza that leads to him getting his name
later in the episode she literally calls him
lucky the pizza dog and we find out more about
what's going on with her mother's business bishop
security she uses software to track people on her
phone which seems kind of shady to begin with but
it does kind of explain where all of her mother's
money is coming from like earlier in the episode
she referenced building her business from the
ground up like she's not someone who came from
money which i think is another connection to the
kingpin because kingpin kind of did the same thing
she winds up following the trail of evidence back
to armond's and finds his body also makes note of
the monogram butterscotch candy i don't know what
the deal with butterscotch candy and old people is
but even in real life my own grandparents always
had butterscotch candy in their house i don't know
what the deal is i think it's just something
with old people maybe the butterscotch candy
winds up being a big plot point in episode 2.
i'll talk about that during my episode 2 video
when they pay that off but even at this point
in the episode i feel like most people probably
assumed that the stab wound in the back probably
came from the hawkeye ronin sword because of the
whole inheritance that they were teasing at the
auction swordmaster probably killed him to gain
his inheritance in the fact that kate bishop runs
into the tracksuits right outside of armond's home
kind of confirms that connection making it sound
like swordmaster and kate bishop's mother were
connected to the tracksuits which were raiding
that black market auction she winds up trying to
take them all on by herself until hawkeye himself
shows up to try and find out what's going on with
this new mystery ronin which he saw in the news
like oh hell no what's going on with that ronin
costume what is this coming back to haunt me he
winds up kicking all their asses pretty easily
and then rips her mask off and they end on that
moment like wait a minute who the hell are you
paying off the title of the episode never meet
your heroes as kate bishop comes face to face with
her hero hawkeye if you spotted any big easter
eggs in the episode that i didn't reference in
the video just write them below in the comments
like i said my episode 2 video will post next
later tonight it'll take me a little while to
finish the video but that should be up pretty soon
each of the episodes after this will just air
one per week like normal you can click here
for that hawkeye episode 2 video i'll update
the link as soon as i post the video and you
can click here for my new spider-man no way home
trailer video with venom and morbius easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!